[Musique]
ce matin à l'Hôtel de Ville de Paris
certains ont reçu un accueil VIP le
département organise aujourd'hui son
rendez-vous annuel de fin d'année pour
les réunionnés bénéficiir du dispositif
d'accompagnement des
malades venu pour une transplantation
cardiaque et là sur la liste d'attente
très retrouve au loin et là-bas chez moi
habitué voir toujours la fête en fin
d'année un petit peu partout avec les
amis avec la famille voilà et ici pas
pareil ben là c'est comme un famille ici
en fin de compte qu mais m' pascore
rencontre de monde mais on verra bien
dans les difficultés auxquelles vous
faites face nous sommes présents et nous
pensons à
vous
surtout je veux vous
adresser au nom du Président de
l'ensemble des conseillers
départementant et en mon nom personnel
nos vœux de bonnes fête de Bonne Année
2024 que la joie la solidarité et
surtout la santé vous
accompagne et les équipes du département
ont tout fait pour remplir les cœurs des
familles de l'esprit de Noël au
programme notamment un atelier
sapin alors le principe c'est que vous
puissiez prendre votre sapin il avec des
petites décoration vous pouvez faire
votre sapin et après on vous emballe ça
vous pourouvez repartir avec pour que
vous puissiez avoir votre petit sapin
Noël de quoi ravir les petits élégants
et ramener de la chaleur pays dans le
cœur de chacun ça fait chaud au cœur
franchement on n'est pas oublié c'est
super franchement on se sentait un peu
seul là donc bravo chacun repartira avec
son sapin de quoi égayer les lieux
d'hébergement des malades et de leur
familles un espace photo souvenir a été
également prévu redonner du sourire et
de la légèreté à ses familles une fierté
pour le département on a eu la chance
d'accueillir aujourd'hui les partenaires
du dispositif dans le but de présenter
donc le dispositif de manière Surin afin
de prévoir une manière de travailler en
partenariat pour les personnes malades
et leurs accompagnants je suis tellement
émue de voir ces gens-là de voir que que
ces malades là sont ces gensl sont
contents de de voir les r de voir les
réunionner ici ben le département il est
là pour leur donner espoir et rien de
mieux pour recharger les batteries qu'un
bon déjeuner
retrouver les racines retrouver les gens
un moment et tout c'est ça ça fait
plaisir on est loin de la famillerouver
des Ronn partager un bon moment c'est
bien c'est comme
ça en bon animateur de la journée Maroni
donne le ton place à la
[Musique]
musique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il est convivial nous retrouve d'autres
personnes le département la Réunion ben
il soutient beaucoup les réunionnés et
les réconfortant de savoir que nous les
pasarués ici malgré les inconvénients
que n peut traverser rencontrer chaque
jour
[Musique]
et pour finir cette journée en beauté
tout le monde a pu repartir avec son
cadeau des pour les plus jeunes et un
sac de prod du pays pour tout le
monde c'est un bilan très positif et
voir les sourires de T des malades qui
se sont pas sentis malades qui ont crase
même un timaloya aujourd'hui c'était
vraiment quelque chose de très bien et
que je pense que c'est à refaire et le
Père Noël bien passé pour nous hein
c'est bien continue comme
[Musique]
ça